Hallo, ich hab zwei Fragen an Chad
Ich wuerde gerne wissen, ob dein Hals manchmal wehtut, nachdem ihr ein Konzert gegeben habt.
Und meine zweite Frage ist, ob du dich manchmal mit deinem Bruder streitest und wie es ist, mit ihm zusammen in einer Band zu spielen.
Erst einmal danke, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, mir diese Fragen zu stellen
Das ist das zweite Mal, dass man mich das heute fragt, ob mein Hals nach einem Konzert wehtut.
Er tut nie weh. es ist immer nur eine Frage, ob es am naechsten Tag noch weitergehen kann oder nicht.
Wenn ich zu viel schreie, weiss ich, dass es mich fuer den Auftritt am naechsten Tag ihn Schwierigkeiten bringen koennte.
Darum belasse ich es manchmal einfach nur beim Gesang und lass es Ufer die Stimmbaender etwas ruhiger angehen.
Und zu deiner zweiten Frage, ob Mike und ich uns hin und wieder streiten.
Das hatten wir mal. Bevor wir einen Plattenvertrag hatten und quer durch Kanada gereist sind.
Und dass mit einem Van, wo es natuerlich sehr eng war. Das ist so eine typische Situation, wo Geschwister sich ordentlich streiten.
Und mittlerweile streiten wir uns nicht mehr wirklich, weil wir uns auch nicht mehr den ganzen Tag hindurch sehen.
Ich bin in meinem Bus, er ist in seinem und Ryan ist auch seinem eigenen Bus
Und wenn wir uns dann vor einer Show in der Umkleide treffen, laecheln wir uns normalerweise breit an und fragen den anderen: Hey, und was hast du heute gemacht?
Wir sind also nicht die Gallagher Brueder von Oasis, falls du das hšren wolltest